is going to happen i am going to have to
fix you manage you to on a more personal
scale
a a more micro form of management jim
what is that called microgemint boom yes
now jim is going to be the client dwight
you're going to have to sell to him
without being aggressive hostile or
difficult let's go all right fine
[Music]
hello hello this is dwight schrute from
the dunder mifflin paper company well
that's great because i need paper
excellent then you were in luck because
we are having a limited time offer only
on everything wow this is my lucky day
what is your name sir i am bill
buttlicker
really that's your real name
how dare you
my family built this country by the way
are you respectful dwight please oh yes
michael could you hold on one second
that's my other line what no but i hello
yeah
no i'm just on the phone with this
stupid salesman he's so dumb
probably just gonna keep him on the line
forever and not buy anything
okay it's up to you to change his mind
sorry that was a family emergency oh no
what's wrong you know what that's
private
boundaries dwight come on i'm sorry mr
butt licker as i was saying
we're having a limited a little bit
louder i'm hard of hearing he's sorry if
he's an old man okay as i was saying
right now we are talking louder okay our
prices have never been low you have to
talk louder never been lower louder son
buttocker our prices have never been
lower
that is totally inappropriate
you never yell at the client no you
listen to me sir here we go the three
words i would describe you as is
aggressive yes hostile and definitely
difficult please mr buy my rate right
give me the please please give me
another chance give me the phone mr butt
licker give me the phone i have to put
you on with my boss well i should hope
so who is this hello this is michael
scott regional manager well this is
william m buttlicker hello mr buttlicker
how may we help you
michael i like the sound of your voice
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna buy
one million dollars worth of paper
products today
see what's done thank you very much sir
i don't think you'll regret it
you are the master there is one
condition michael yes you have to fire
the salesman that treated me so terribly
don't do it michael
it's a million dollar sale
[Music]
it's britney [ __ ]
did you forget something
what happened to you guys give it back
the gift basket give it back what is
this it's real simple if you don't
appreciate what we do then give us back
our basket maybe you should leave yeah
maybe we should
maybe you should leave come on let's
leave but before we leave my wet friend
and i are gonna wait for our cabs on
your nice
couches can you call us a cab please i'm
gonna oh sorry look my clothes are so
wet wet nice leather
oh my shoes are so muddy
all right here you go take it there
it's been opened yeah it was mine what's
missing
for turtles where are the turtles where
are the turtles come on guys get out of
here where are the turtles
where are they well guess what i just
drove my car into a lake you did what
you stopped yelling
remain calm i have trained for this
okay
exit the window here we go make a u-turn
if possible
[Music]
come on
i drove my car
into a
lake
uh i get it everybody knows about the
ultimatum yes i told everyone
hey
right back at you [ __ ]
what's your daughter's name again peepee
pipa
people how is she great great
well to be fair
jim
james
jimothy to be fair jimothy the ah that
sounds weird
are you okay with being called jim i am
all right the busiest bieber award goes
to phyllis lapin
yeah
way to go phyllis nice work
per usual this says bushiest beaver
i told them busiest idiots it's fine
we'll fix it we'll fix it up you don't
have to display that you know what
today
is not a good day for a sales contest
we're not we're not doing this today
that doesn't seem fair you want to talk
about fair does anyone need to smell my
old carpet
you explained to me how that was fair
and i'll explain to you how this is fair
plus i just
i think that picking today was sort of
taking advantage but you're the one who
picked it i
am a victim of a hate crime
stanley knows what i'm talking about
that's not what a hate crime is well i
hated it a lot okay i
well i managed my department and i've
been doing that for several years now
and god i've learned a lot of life
lessons along the way
your department's just you right yes jim
but i am not easy to manage you know
your partner's got a lot of attitude but
i like that how long you guys been
dating jim couldn't land me in a
thousand years but you're saying there's
a chance shut up seriously you're gonna
send me back
uh yeah it's the safest part of a car in
the event of a crash driver always
protects his side first
yeah that's no problem pam sure
uh-huh bam knock knock i'm on the phone
i know you are knock knock you can fax
it over yeah five seven zero
five five nine one
zero one four
five
length
zero one seven five thank you
bye-bye
it really makes us look unprofessional
they would never know it was me doing it
here we go knock knock
who's there
buddha buddha who buddha this bread for
me won't you
great i i need something to wipe my hand
no there's there's butter
it was a classic i got a knock-knock
joke no okay michael please please
please please
please let me all right
who's there
kgb kg level asked that question what
the hell was that what are you doing
what are you doing hey hey stop it stop
being like hey come on what are you
doing man it's part of a hilarious job
why is retribution what are you doing no
more knock knock jokes that's it ding
dong
who's there kgb
do i get the door i'm not answering
answer this
no way it's the key thing though i'm not
answering that yes you're going you
answer i'm not gonna answer i'm not
gonna enter into kgb the kgb will fit
for no one
it's true
you